What is the Gospel and how should we read it?
Popular opinion may think that the gospels are biographies of Jesus,
but they're not biographies,
at least not a new thing like the modern sense.
We don't get much of a personal portrait of Jesus from the Gospels.
We don't know anything about how he developed,
how he went from being an obnoxious teenager to being an apocalyptic prophet.
We don't know him about his relationship to his parents,
his brothers and sisters.
We don't know.
We don't know all kinds of things that a modern biography would automatically be
expected to tell you.
So the gospels aren't biographies.
Somebody has one set of scholar,
one's called mark a passion narrative with an extended introduction.
Well,
what's a passion?
Narrative?
Passion comes from the Latin Passio,
which doesn't mean just desire.
It could mean that in the actual world,
but it also means suffering.
Suffering is what passio means,
and so it's the suffering of Jesus that happens at his arrest,
his trial,
His crucifixion,
and the resurrection.
All of that's part of what scholars call the passion narrative.
And if you notice that occupies a huge part of the gospel of mark.
The Gospel of Mark is our shortest gospel that's in the Canon.
It's only 16 chapters in your course.
The chapters and verse numbers weren't there and the original manuscripts,
it was just written.
In fact,
they even divide up words and they had very little punctuation.
It was just one capitol letter after another,
which is one of the reasons that ancient people tended to read text out loud.
They didn't read silently to themselves and whether he is cause it was easier to
read a text that had node word divisions.
It was all capital letters,
no punctuation.
And it wasn't divided up into sentences.
It was much easier to read that if you read it out loud to yourself.
So that's the way ancient people read.
But so we don't have chapter numbers and verse divisions.
Those are all later creations that came about in the Middle Ages in
Christianity.
But,
uh,
there's if by modern reckoning,
therefore they're 16 chapters in mark,
that's the shortest gospel.
And of that one third of mark is just the last week of Jesus' life.
The Passion narrative part of it.
So one does a scholar said,
mark is really a passion narrative with an extended introduction.
Notice what you get if you have an outline of mark chapter one verse one is the
title,
the Young Deleon or the gospel of uh,
according to Jesus,
you know,
Jesus Christ.
And uh,
it doesn't say according to mark in the title because that name was led,
edited later.
That's the title of the book.
And then for the next few verses from one to that is chapter one,
verse two to verse 13 you get an initial introduction to Jesus,
just a little bit about him.
Then from one 14 to nine 50.
So nine chapters is Jesus has Galilean ministry.
His healings,
his teachings is traveling around his miracles that all take place in Galilee,
which is where he's from.
That's of course the northern part of Palette of Palestine where it's Judea is
down in the southern part of Palestine and then versus chapters 11 through 15
are all just the last week in Jerusalem.
Again,
five chapters,
Justin is last week.
And then chapter 16 one through eight is rumors of the resurrection.
Why do I say rumors of the resurrection?
Because if you'll notice in the gospel of Mark,
if mark ends at Chapter 16,
Verse Eight,
and there's been some controversy about whether it really is supposed to end
there,
but in most of your modern additions,
it ends at 16 eight.
If that's true,
you don't actually see the resurrected Jesus.
You just get,
he doesn't appear on the stage,
so to speak.
You only get reports that he has been raised or one report that he's raised.
And then the women are told by this young man who's sitting at the tomb,
probably supposed to represent an angel,
uh,
to go and tell the other disciples that he's raised and he'll go before them to
Galilee.
But notice the women don't tell them that says the women were afraid and they
ran away.
So you don't even get mini reports about Jesus' resurrection.
In mark.
You just get the one young man at the tune telling the women that he's been
raised.
So a huge bulk of the book tells us about the last week of Jesus' life.
And even in the previous 10 chapters of the book,
you have Jesus talking about his upcoming crucifixion.
So these passion predictions we call them,
did occur in the gospel.
You have several of those in the gospel of mark.
So there are several references to use this upcoming death that focuses our
attention even more on the last part of the book.
Is that important?
Does that tell us anything about what sort of thing Mark's Gospel is?
If it's not a biography,
let's look at the ending also mark 16 now remember I want you to bring your
bibles to class.
Why do I want you to bring your bibles to class?
Yes.
Cause I will lie to you.
I may say something that's not true and you need to check me out.
They all knew boost to be tandem.
When the Sabbath was over.
Mark 16 Mary Magdalene and Mary,
the mother of James and Salome brought spices so that they might go and anoint
him.
And very early on,
the first day of the week when the sun had risen,
they went to the tomb.
They had been saying to one another who will roll away the stone for us from the
entrance to the tomb.
When they looked up,
they saw that the stone,
which was very large,
had already been rolled back as they entered the tomb.
They saw a young man dressed in a white robe sitting on the right side and they
were alarmed,
but he said to them,
do not be alarmed.
You are looking for Jesus of Nazareth who was crucified.
He's been raised but he's not here.
Look,
there is the place they laid him,
but go tell his disciples and Peter that he is going ahead of you to Galilee.
There you will see him just as he told you.
So they went out and fled from the tomb for terror and amazement has seized them
and they said nothing to anyone for they were afraid.
Now you'll notice there's,
and maybe some of your bibles,
there will be a paragraph into that titled a shorter ending,
the shorter ending of mark.
All the had been a commanded them.
They briefly told her those around Peter afterward.
Jesus himself went through them from east to west,
the sacred,
imperishable proclamation of eternal salvation.
And then you'll notice there's maybe a few paragraphs call by your editors,
the longer ending of mark,
and it has several verses.
I'm not gonna Bother to read that to you,
but if you look at that,
the little incidents,
Sarah,
the incidents in that longer ending of mark could sound familiar to you.
If you know the other gospels that how they end,
what scholars now believe is that the,
probably the gospel of Mark Really did end at chapter 16 verse eight some people
said,
well,
that's no way to end a book.
The women don't tell anything.
It just as they were afraid and they run away.
That's it.
And even in the Greek that it ends in is a very short little sentence.
That's an odd way to end a book in Greek.
So some people sought,
scholars have said,
well,
maybe that wasn't originally ending.
Maybe mark was riding along.
He got 69 and he fell over and died.
Of a heart attack or maybe he left the manuscript out and some mice ate at the
end of it because you know,
you roll up a scroll and just have the leftover parts of the at the bar back or
maybe it got in a fire and burnt maybe the last few verses.
The last part of the,
the Gospel Burnt,
obviously ancient people had the same sense of uneasiness with the way with mark
ending at 16 eight and what you got in that shorter ending of the longer ending,
we're later compositions of scribes,
Christian scribes who thought you can't end Mark's gospel that way.
So they made up those other verses and they put them at the end of the
manuscript.
They were copying,
because you remember before,
before printing presses,
all manuscripts had to be made one by one by somebody sitting down with a quill
and ink and Papayas and just copying it word by word.
So other scribes when copying this over must've added that on.
In fact that it looks very much like the longer ending.
It was scribes who knew some events from the other gospels and they took some
events from Matthew,
Luke,
and John,
and they stuck them into a little paragraph and they say,
well,
that must be the way mark really intended to end his Gospel in the 20th century.
Basically,
modern scholars have come to pretty much reject most of those theories and at
least we take the gospel of Mark as ending at 16 eight even intentionally.
But if you do that,
then you still have to explain why and a gospel this way.
It's not a normal way to end the book and it's not the way the other gospels end
at all.
So the,
the very ending of mark is one of the problems of the text that scholars feel
like we have to deal with.
This all demonstrates though that scholars don't read the Gospels as
biographies,
three Ds or as even straightforward accounts of events.
Last time I tried to show you how you can't take the book of acts and Paul's
letters as simply being a historical description of what happened because each
of these documents had agendas.
These authors had things that points they to get across these.
We learned to read these gospels in 20th century by the using the,
uh,
method of historical criticism.
The criticism part of that doesn't mean necessarily being critical of it.
That is criticizing the texts.
It just means reading it with critical eyes,
with questioning eyes with if you were doubting eyes in some cases.
But what we do is we read these texts,
not for what they tell us about the events in the past,
although you can read this,
but we actually read the text as if they were intentional documents written by
authors who had points they want it to make and they tell the story the way they
tell the story because they have a message that the important thing is not what
really happened or what lies behind the text for modern scholars.
Most of the time,
unless you're doing historical Jesus Research,
and I'll lecture about that at one period in later,
but most of the time we're saying what did mark as an author want to do?
And therefore we say,
why would he in the Gospel this way?
Uh,
if he did that.
Now that's notice this historical critical method,
which is what I'm teaching in this class is somewhat different from several
other ways of reading text.
And I'm not implying by this the historical critical method is the correct
method all we'll give you the correct meaning of the text.
I believe that it's perfectly legitimate for Christians,
for example,
to read these texts,
to get something religious out of the text for their lives,
from personal guidance,
for doctrine,
for images of Jesus to help their relationship to God,
whatever.
That's a perfectly legitimate way in my view,
to read a text to read it theologically,
but a theological reading the text is not the same thing as a historical
critical reading of the text.
The historian is what I'm playing my role here in this class.
I don't care whether these texts have anything theological to say to you or to
me personally,
what I care about is what kind of theological message was this original writer
intending to give and to whom was he intending to give it?
So the theological way to reading is one way perfectly fine way,
but it's not the historical critical reading necessarily.
They're also literary ways of reading these texts.
And this has been a very common thing in English departments,
uh,
for uh,
you know,
people to write an account of the gospel of mark.
It's been a particularly
significant gospel for modern literary people to retail or talk about the gospel
of Mark,
do a literary reading of it and they're,
they're looking for things like the plot of it,
the way it accomplishes its story is there,
are there figures and characters and what kind of thing does this character
represent or what kind of thing does this event represent symbolically or
literarily?
So just as you know how to do a literary reading of a novel,
some modern scholars will redo a literary reading of the Gospels.
It's a perfectly legitimate way to read the gospels.
It's just not the one that I'm going to concentrate on in this class.
And there are many,
many others you could say,
I'm going to do a deconstruction is poststructuralist reading of mark and they
had been done.
You can go buy books that have done it,
you can do a structuralist reading of mark,
and those are the dullest ones of hall.
So lots of different ways to read these texts.
And I'm going to teach you the historical critical reading,
which means certain things.
It means we're not going to read the gospel of Mark Through the Lens of Matthew,
Luke,
or John.
We're going to take marks on gospel as standing on its own.
So we're not going to rush off to another gospel or to act or the letters of
Paul to provide an interpretive clue for how to read.
Mark.
We're gonna read mark as mark by itself.
And that's one of the fundamental rules of historical criticism is don't
harmonize different texts in the Bible.
Take them each individually.
Uh,
another one is you have to avoid anachronism.
That is,
you can't attribute a meaning to the text of mark.
That doesn't make sense in the first century,
in his own context.
For example,
if you're a Christian,
you're going to read some of the songs in the Hebrew Bible as being about Jesus.
Probably most Christians do.
So when the psalmist says,
the Lord said to my Lord,
sit at my right hand and I'll make your enemies your footstool.
Christians have traditionally said the first Lord,
there is God.
And the second Lord is Jesus.
And this is uh,
an old testament reference to the fuck God,
the father and God the son.
And this is a Christological song that's a theological wavering.
The Psalm,
it doesn't pass the test of historical criticism because historians will point
out,
look,
the original som is,
didn't know anything about Jesus.
He wasn't prophesying about Jesus personally.
He was talking probably to the Davidic king today.
The song's meant to talk to David or to David's descendants who sit on the
throne of Judah.
So anachronism has to be avoided in historical critical readings.
And there are several other kinds of clues that you're doing a historical
reading rather than a theological reading or literary reading.
And you'll pick up on those as we go through the class.
In fact,
in your sections,
not this time,
but next time you will actually talk about how to write an Exige Jesus paper
because you'll be writing one and your section leaders will lead you through
this method and try to get you to see how it's done.
If we're going to do that though,
let's imagine what kind of community,
this ancient guy,
we're going to call mark,
we're gonna continue to call him mark,
even though we don't believe that it was the historical John Mark who wrote the
Gospel.
But for convenience sake,
we just call him the Gospel Writers,
Matthew,
Mark,
Luke,
and John for convenience sake.
So what kinds of,
what did mark want to do with this text?
Who did he want to do it with?
What kind of historical context do we imagine?
And first we see immediately we see a bunch of problems with this text.
There's first the problem when the most famous problems of the messianic secret.
This is when over and over again mark,
and it happens sometimes in the other gospels,
but it's,
it happens more in mark than a lot of other places.
You get Jesus doing something and then he tells somebody to be too quiet about
what he's just done.
Looking at one 25 mark one 25 he's just cast.
He has,
he's confronted an unclean spirit.
The unclean spirit cried out.
What have you to do with us?
Jesus of Nazareth have you come to destroy us?
I know who you are,
the holy one of God.
In other words,
the unclean spirit has just made a correct Christological confession according
to the gospel of mark,
but Jesus rebuked him saying,
be silent and come out of him and the unclean spirit convulsing and crying out
with a loud voice came out of him.
Look at one 34th Chapter 34 right below that.
He cured many who are sick with various diseases and cast out many demons,
but he would not permit the demons to speak because they knew him.
Wait a minute.
If Jesus is going around and we're supposed to think that he's announcing that
he is the Messiah,
the Christ,
when people recognize this,
why doesn't he let them speak?
Why does he tell them not to speak?
And so he does this with demons a lot,
but it's not just demons that he commands to silence.
He also does it to people.
Look at one 43 [inaudible] immediately the leprosy left him this man.
Let's try verse 42 and he was made clean after sternly warning him.
He sent him away at once,
sang to him,
see that you say nothing to anyone,
but go show yourself to the priest.
Offer your cleansing what Moses commanded as a testimony to them.
So it's a testimony to the fact that he's now no longer a leper,
but he tells the men,
don't tell anybody about the miracle.
Yeah.
Uh,
one,
five 53.
Now also notice what happens right below that in fort chip,
verse 45,
but he went out to the man did and began to proclaim it freely and to spread the
word so that Jesus could no longer go into a town openly,
but stayed out in the country and people came to him from every quarter.
So Jesus does some great act.
He tells the person,
the demon of the person,
don't tell anybody.
The person goes out and tells people.
Anyway,
it's a pattern.
So this is what we call the one of the old theories about the messianic secret
was a modern scholar in the early 20th century said,
well,
here's what happened.
The disciples of Jesus,
the say,
the Gospel,
the writer of the gospel of mark knew that Jesus wasn't proclaimed openly and
widely as the Messiah during Jesus's own lifetime.
He was proclaimed as a messiah by Jesus,
the disciples after his death.
So why didn't all these people recognize Jesus was the Messiah during his
lifetime?
And so the scholar said,
well,
the writer of the gospel of mark decided it must have been cut.
Jesus kept it a secret.
Jesus wanted to keep it a secret.
Now the problem with that theory is can you pick out the problem with that
theory?
The reason we have the messianic secret and mark is because people knew that
Jesus was not openly proclaimed to the Messiah during his lifetime.
So this was a literary device to explain why Jesus wasn't known as lifetime is
because Jesus kept it a secret.
What's wrong with this theory?
Yes ma'am.
Yep.
There's one place where he does say go tell the binding of the strong man other
problems with the theory
the people tell anyway,
so it doesn't explain that Jesus wasn't proclaimed in the PSI because all the
people that tell us to be quiet go and proclaim him anyway.
And it just says his fame spread.
So there's been a lot of other theories about this whole messianic secret.
What does it mean?
Why does he tell people to be quiet?
What is it that he wants them to keep quiet and why did they go tell him,
tell about him anyway,
what does that mean for the story?
That's the first,
the second problem.
The problem of misunderstanding.
Look at Mark Two 16
uh,
when the scribes of the Pharisees saw that he was eating with sinners and tax
collectors,
they said to his disciples,
why does he eat with tax collectors and sinners?
When Jesus heard this,
he said to them,
those who are well,
instead what I want to read,
okay,
well,
look at 1534 I think I can make this point better with a couple of other texts.
This point is that the point I'm making is that people tend to misunderstand
Jesus,
his sayings and off often events.
At three o'clock,
Jesus cried out with our loud voice.
This is when he's crucified.
Loi,
Lama Sabachthani,
which means it's Aramaic.
It means my God,
my God,
why have you forsaken me?
When some of the bystanders heard it,
they said,
listen,
he's calling for Elijah.
What does not count for Elijah?
It's just that the word,
that Aramaic word,
Ella,
Ella is sounds like the name of Ligeia.
So people standing around misunderstand things that are happening,
did it,
but it's not just people standing around the disciples in mark,
the disciples themselves,
the people who are closest to Jesus are the ones who get it wrong the most.
I hope you notice this when you were reading this text before class,
is that repeatedly Jesus has to explain things to Peter and James and John,
his closest disciples for 41 [inaudible].
Yeah.
He said to them,
why are you afraid?
Have you still no faith?
In other words,
they've already seen him do all kinds of miracles by this point in mark,
and they were filled with great Oland said to another who then is this that even
the wind and the sea obey him?
Well,
where are the readers?
We're going?
You learn to that.
And the first verse,
sign of God.
Hmm.
All the way through here,
we've been just been telling people what he is,
or at least demons have another people and people had been confessing and yet
the disciples don't understand.
Uh,
six 52.
Now notice my point about this is not to say that historically Jesus,
his disciples actually didn't understand.
We're not looking for what happened.
What we're looking for is the narrative structure.
What,
what store,
what kind of story the author tells and why does he tell it this way?
Six 52,
um,
start reading at say 51.
Then he got out of the boat.
This is when Jesus,
you know,
doing another kind of see miracle.
He got out into the boat with them and the wind ceased and they were utterly
astounded.
Four,
they did not understand about the loaves,
but their hearts were hardened.
In other words,
Jews had multiplied loaves and fishes and a previous scene.
They should have picked up on that,
that he somehow special
somehow they didn't understand what special about Jesus.
It goes all the way at seven,
18,
a eight,
six,
17 through 21 over and over again.
Just if when you're studying mark,
go through and mark the different times when somebody gets it wrong,
even when they should not have gotten it wrong.
There are people who recognize them.
The first person who recognizes Jesus in the gospel of Mark is you because the
very first verse announces the beginning of the good news you Angeli on in Greek
meaning just good announcement,
good news of Jesus Christ,
the son of God.
Now some manuscripts don't have that verse quite like that,
but if that's the original wording of the of that verse,
you have been told from the very first verse that Jesus is the Son of God.
It's not a mystery to you,
the reader.
That's part of the fun of the gospel of this.
Mark and John both play with this.
They let you the reader in on certain kinds of jokes and puzzles that the people
in the story don't get.
So that's one of the things that mark is doing is letting you in on some things,
but still it's very difficult for us to figure out this whole messianic secret
thing and this lack of understanding.
Even though we'd been on the secret and the last person to know who Jesus is and
to recognize them and not to misunderstand is this interior at the cross in 1539
the Roman centurion,
when Jesus dies says this,
and now I'll do it the way the greatest story ever told the movie.
This scene is played by John Wayne.
He's the Roman Centurion and you don't really see John Wayne.
Clearly you'd see a shadow with the sun coming in and Jesus just died on the
cross.
And then you hear this over voice over voice.
Surely there's was us,
son of God,
John Wayne,
invitation for you.
So this material though recognizes that Jesus,
son of God,
at least the court,
if that's the way we read,
that the other people who recognize Jesus and understand our demons,
at least they recognize him.
Now let's look at the turning point in the gospel.
And what I'm going to do is show you how I,
as a brilliant modern scholar,
has posed these problems.
The Messianic secret problem,
the problem of misunderstanding and all this sort of thing.
And now and the problem of the ending,
which I'll get to in a minute and I'm going to make it all make sense for you.
There are other scholars who might not think I'm so brilliant and might have
other explanations,
but this one's mine and I'm sticking to it.
[inaudible] eight 27
follow along with me in your hymnals.
Eight 27 Jesus went on with his disciples to the villages of Cesarea,
Philippon and on the way he asks his disciples,
who do people say that I am?
Okay,
nice little introduction.
You're a smart readers.
As soon as you get to this part,
you go,
okay,
we're getting to the climax of this book because all the way through the book,
up to this point,
we've had this issue of who is he?
Who Do people say is how do they understand him?
So you should your,
your antenna should be picking up that this story is going to be an important
story for you.
And they answered him,
John the Baptist and others,
Elijah and still love this one of the prophets.
He asked them,
but who do you say that I am?
Peter answered him,
you are the Messiah and he sternly ordered them not to tell anyone about him.
There it is again.
Peter confesses correctly,
you are the Messiah and Jesus says,
okay,
don't tell anybody.
[inaudible] is not very good evangelist.
Apparently he's not Joel Ornstein or whoever that guy is in Houston.
He's not the kind who is proclaiming it all out,
at least according to the gospel of mark.
Then he began to teach them.
Now wait a minute,
that might be important.
He just did this command to silence.
What is the next verse say?
Then he began to teach them that the son of man must undergo great suffering.
Then he began to teach them.
Then he began to teach them not before.
Then he began to teach them that the son of man must undergo great suffering,
be rejected by the elders,
the chief priests and scribes and be killed and after three day rise again,
he said all this quite openly.
Mark is a clever writer.
He puts little short sentences like this and his Gospel at interesting places
and you are,
the reader is supposed to go,
okay,
he's talking right to me.
He said this openly,
it's not closed anymore.
This part's open.
This part's not closed,
but it's not going to be the end of the problem.
And Peter took him aside and began to rebuke him,
but turning and looking at his disciples,
he rebuked Peter Peter's course saying something like,
no,
Jesus.
You didn't get it.
We just said,
you're the messiah.
The Messiah doesn't suffer and die on a cross.
The Messiah comes with angels and rules the world,
the Messiah overthrows the Romans,
the messiah sets up the new reconstituted Israel and all the nations will flock
to Jerusalem.
Now you're the messiah.
That's what you do.
No,
no,
you don't suffer and die.
That's not what Messiah is due and this is actually,
you know what?
You know there's no Jewish expectation in the ancient world that the Messiah
would suffer and die.
We Modern Christians think,
well that's of course it's all the way through the Old Testament.
But that those prophecies and things,
those statements and poems in the Old Testament,
they weren't taken to be about the messiah they were taking to be about other
profits are holy men of God who might have to suffer,
who might be persecuted,
but the messiah passages don't have suffering and death in them.
They just refer to this coming king,
the descendant of David.
So no Jews in this,
in the first century,
this time expected that the Messiah would be crucified.
It just was absolutely against common sense.
You just cruise Messiahs don't suffer.
Messiahs aren't crucified.
Messiah is,
aren't,
aren't beaten.
So Peter actually is quite,
quite understandably,
thinks that Jesus has got it wrong.
So Peter says,
you know,
you're the messiah.
You're not,
you're not going to be killed and suffer.
And that's when Jesus turns around and rebukes Peter Looking at his disciples.
Is that an interest?
Include that Jesus is looking at his disciples and he rebukes Peter,
get behind me,
Satan.
For you are setting your mind not on divine things,
but on human things.
So that's a very interesting story in itself.
What is Paul?
What does Jesus rebuking Peter for and calling him Satan.
He called the crowd with his disciples and said to them,
if you want to become my followers,
let them.
If any wants to become my followers,
let them deny themselves and take up their cross and follow me.
For those who want to save their life will lose it for the sake of the Gospel.
Um,
lose their life for my sake and for the sake of the Gospel will save it.
But what would it profit them to gain the whole world and forfeit their life?
Indeed.
What can,
what can they give in return for their life?
Those who are ashamed of me and of my words in this adulterous and sinful
generation of them,
the son of man will also be ashamed when he comes in the glory of his angels,
of his father with the holy angels.
That's what Messiah we're expected to do is come in glory with holy angels.
And he said to them,
truly,
I tell you there are some standing here who will not taste death until they see
that kingdom of God has come with power.
What's going on here?
You have the correct identification of Jesus.
Even according to mark as the Messiah.
You have the charge to secrecy.
In eight 30 you had the passion,
prediction,
one of the passion predictions of the first of several that we'll see in mark
Jesus saying,
this is going to happen,
and then you hit this word and he said this plainly and clearly to them and I
said,
no clue.
Then you have Peter's misunderstanding,
but what does Peter Misunderstand?
That's what we'll ask.
What was it Peter expecting different while he was expecting the Messiah to come
with angels and triumphant.
Then you have an emphasis on suffering that everybody has to suffer.
Not just a son of man,
but everybody has to suffer and you have a prediction of future eschatological
glory.
Eschatology is just a fancy theological word,
meaning the end times,
the study of the end times as cotton is just a Greek word,
meaning the end.
Yeah.
You'll see this.
If you read much about the new,
the Bible or ancient religion,
the eschaton will come up in apocalyptic context and eschatology means any study
or doctrine about the end of the world as we know it.
In fact,
I used to direct a little singing group and the divinity school when I was a
Grad student here and we called ourselves the ESCA tones,
a joke that only divinity students would get.
So the the prediction of the eschatological glory that comes after the suffering
and then right after that,
six to six days later,
Jesus took with him,
Peter and James and John led them up to a high mountain apart by themselves and
he was transfigured before them and his clothes became dazzling white such as no
one on earth could bleach them and they appeared to them.
Elijah with Moses and Elijah with Moses who we're talking with Jesus.
Peter says to Jesus,
rabbi,
it's good for us to be here.
Let us make three dwellings,
three tabernacles,
three tents,
one for you,
one for Moses and one for Elijah.
He did not know what to say for they were terrified.
Then a cloud overshadowed them and from the cloud there came a voice.
This is my son,
the beloved,
listen to him.
Suddenly when they looked around,
they saw no one with him anymore,
but only Jesus.
The next verse,
and they were coming down the mountain as argument.
He ordered them to tell no one what they had seen.
Again,
that secrecy motif until the son of man had risen from the dead and again and
it's just on death.
What's going on with all this?
What's going on is that mark is trying to make an important point maybe even to
his fellow believers at the time.
Apparently
Mark's basically what peer doesn't understand about Jesus is that Jesus has to
suffer and has to die and if that causes a redefinition of Peter's notion of
what a messiah is,
so be it.
Peter needs to work with a redefined notion of the Christ,
the Messiah,
if he doesn't include the necessity of suffering in that notion.
Let's look,
let's imagine the context for this kind of message.
The rapid fire style of mark is one of the,
if you noticed,
did you notice how many times immediately is used the word immediately,
the writer of the Gospel,
Martin needed a good Yale college editor or a writing tutor because it's kind of
a rapid fire is not written very good Greek style either is rapid fire exists
immediately.
This happened then immediately this happened in the meeting and said,
you get the idea reading Guzman mark,
that the narrative is,
is pulling you along,
is shoving you along as is rushing you along.
That's actually part of,
I think,
this apocalyptic style of Mark Because the gospel of mark is also apocalyptic in
its message.
It talks about angels coming at the end.
It talks about a big war that's going to happen,
so you have demons and the battle of Jesus with the strong man.
Another apocalyptic story.
You have the emphasis on suffering and persecution and that's a common theme of
Jewish apocalyptic.
Not that the Messiah would suffer,
but that the Jews themselves might have to suffer before the fabulous kingdom of
the end time.
Remember you saw it in Daniel.
When we read Daniel Two classes ago,
Daniel predicts suffering for the righteous and only after the suffering would
you have the goodies heaven,
the Kingdom of God.
Now we look at mark 13 we're going to analyze it pretty carefully because again,
some of these things will come into play.
The basic message I'm saying is that people misunderstand about Jesus is they
misunderstand the necessity of suffering that must be there before you.
It must precede glory.
Yes,
God promises them glory.
They're going to be glorified in the end.
They're gonna win in the end,
but they have to go through a period of suffering.
Jesus is the first one who does this.
He accepts suffering and death before he himself is glorified,
but the glory will come.
It has to be preceded by suffering,
but Jesus also in mark tells the disciples over and over again,
you also will have to suffer first,
but if you endure,
you will experience glory.
Also Nicola Mark 13
as he came out of the temple,
one of his disciples said to him,
look,
teacher,
what large stones and what large buildings,
and Jesus asked him,
do you see these great buildings?
Not One stone will be left here upon another.
All will be thrown down.
So he's predicting the destruction of the temple in Jerusalem when he was
sitting on the Mount of Olives opposite the temple,
Peter,
James,
John,
and Andrew asked him privately,
tell us when will this be and what will be the sign that all these things are to
be accomplished.
Then Jesus began to say them,
but where that no one leads you astray.
Many will come in my name and say,
I am he and they will lead me astray.
So false prophets do you just predict there'll be false profits,
maybe even false messiahs although he doesn't use that term here in mark it
there will occur in other places.
When you hear of wars and rumors of wars do not be alarmed.
This must take place,
but the end is still to come.
So just when people have the,
when times are bad in,
there are wars,
that's not necessarily the end yet.
You've got to have few of those for nation will rise against nation,
kingdom against kingdom.
There will be earthquakes in various places,
famines,
but it is the but the beginning of the birth pangs as for yourself,
beware for,
they will hand you over to the councils.
You will be beaten in synagogues again,
this theme of suffering.
So you have all these terrible cosmic events,
terrible wars and disasters,
earthquakes and all that sort of thing.
But also he says you're going to have to suffer.
They're going to hand you over for persecution in 1310 and the good news must
first be proclaimed to all nations.
So Jesus is predicting that before the incomes,
his message,
the Gospel message will be proclaimed all around.
And even though you have worse things happening,
1312 brother will betray brother to death of father,
his child,
child and children will rise against parents and have them put to death and you
will be hated by all because of my name,
but the one who endures to the end will be saved.
In other words,
familial divisions,
even the households will be torn apart by the suffering,
by the conflict,
and then 1314 but when you see the desolating sacrilege set up where it ought
not to be.
Now here's one of those little phrases.
Let the reader understand.
The author is giving you a very,
very clear clue that this is when you really better be paying attention.
Let the reader understand when you see the desolating sacrilege set up where it
ought not to be.
Have we heard that before?
The abomination of desolation is that King James,
English,
English translation of it.
The desolating sacrilege is often when it's translated in more modern bibles at
our first,
at the same language,
wherever we heard about the abomination of desolation being set up where it
ought not to be set up before Daniel.
The words come right out of Daniel.
They occur three of course,
Daniel was written in a combination of Hebrew and Aramaic,
and this is in Greek,
but this is the Greek translation.
You have it in Daniel nine 27.
Daniel 1131 and Daniel 1211.
So this Jesus has read his Daniel
and then you have warnings in row woes,
uh,
verses 15 through 13.
So you have all this stuff,
but now what happens after that?
The one who in the house got,
must not go down to into the house to take anything away.
The one in the field must not turn back to the coat.
Woe to those who are pregnant to those who are nursing infants in those days,
pray that it may not be in winter for in those days,
there will be suffering such as not even from the beginning of creation that God
and never will be.
And if the Lord had not cut short those days,
no one will be saved.
Now notice we're not getting any more historical events here.
We're not getting any more stuff happening except right then he says,
if anyone says to you,
look,
here's the Messiah,
or look,
there he is.
Do not believe it.
False Messiah is false profits,
so this is more false besides him,
all false profits in those days after that suffering.
Now here's where you really get the cataclysmic end.
The world crashing down.
The Sun will be darkened.
The moon will not give it's light.
Stars will fall from the skies.
The powers in the heavens will be shaken.
Then you will see the son of man coming in clouds with great glory and power.
Then he will send out the angels and gather his elect from the four winds,
from the ends of the Earth to the ends of Heaven.
When does it happen?
Right after the abomination of desolation is set up where it ought not to be.
What is the abomination of desolation?
Well,
we don't know some.
Obviously if Jesus is reading Daniel,
and this is where getting this,
he also believes that something's going to happen in the temple.
That author Daniel believed it was something that Antioch is the for the
Epiphany's.
May Be sacrificed a pig on the altar or he desecrated somehow the altar in the
holy of holies in the temple.
Jesus says,
doesn't believe that that event was the end event is Daniel thought it was.
Jesus is predicting that this is going to happen.
Something's going to happen in the temple.
There's going to be so awful and it's going to be an abomination.
And once that happens,
then all hell breaks loose.
And when all hell has broken loose the worst,
then the son of man will swoop down with in the clouds with angels and put a
stop to it all.
That'll be the glorification.
Okay,
so when does this happen?
Well,
mark has told us one thing.
It's going to happen during your own generation.
Jesus said,
this generation will not pass away before this stuff happens.
The apostles asked him,
so he said,
well,
it will be within a generation.
And then he says,
now nobody's going to know the exact time,
but once you see the abomination of desolation set up and the temple word all
got to be,
that's when it's going to happen.
Now,
did this happen?
Well,
we're not,
we're not narrated anything about it.
Okay.
What does mark not narrate in this section?
That we as historians know happened with the temple?
What?
What does he do?
What does he not narrate?
Happening is destruction.
Jesus predicts the destruction.
Jesus prophesies about destruction,
but mark doesn't tell us that the temple in Jerusalem are destroyed.
He doesn't tell us explicitly about the Roman armies led by Vespasian and Titus
surrounding Jerusalem and seat besieging it for two years.
He doesn't tell us that in the year 70 the Romans actually did take Jerusalem
and burned the temple,
destroyed the temple.
If mark knew about that,
why didn't he tell us about it?
This is why scholars,
a lot of scholars believe this is exactly like Daniel.
Remember how we said,
how do you date Daniel?
You figure out when does his,
his,
his history gone,
right and when does his sister not go ride anymore?
And if you applied that same standard of tests to this text,
what you've got is a prediction of the temple destruction.
So at least the rider knows that it is likely to happen.
He can see it happening in the future,
but he doesn't narrate it.
Hackman.
Yes sir.
Wow.
Yes.
Conservatives,
conservative Christians know that more than one generation has happened since
that time.
Many,
many,
many generations.
They've taken the,
the Greek word translated here as generation,
which I think is the right translation and they say,
well,
if you,
you know,
you can take that to mean race of people and of course,
what race would they then be referring to?
The Jews and so conservative Christians who don't believe who believe this has
to be an accurate prediction of something that's going to happen in our future.
Also translate that as race or say the generation doesn't refer to a generation
of time of 40 years or so.
It means the race of the Jews,
as long as there are Jews in existence,
then this thing can still go on and hasn't happened yet.
So that explains the translation.
Quite frankly,
I think the translation is just wrong
because it seems to me that the,
that what Mark's intention is to put some kind of time limit on this.
He's trying to get his readers to see a time.
Well,
if you just say the race of the Jews,
then that doesn't give you any sense of time.
You have a question?
Okay,
so where are we now?
I think what's going on is this.
Let's just think of,
imagine this happening 16 one through eight I've already read.
And what happens in 61 through eight the women are told that Jesus has been
raised from the dead as Jesus predicted he would be.
And [inaudible] the young man tells the woman,
go tell his disciples that he will go before the into Galilee.
Go meet him in Galilee.
And in fact earlier in mark in one of these sort of passion predictions,
Jesus had told the disciples once I'm dead and I will go before you to Galilee,
implying that they're supposed to follow him to Galilee.
But then 16 eight ends,
one possible reconstruction for all this.
And this is just an interpretation put out by some scholars excepted by some
rejected by a whole lot of others.
What if mark himself is writing right before the year 70 he knows he maybe he's
even riding in Galilee himself or in some place close to Galilee and he knows
the Romans army went through Galilee first in the year is 66 and 68 and
destroyed lots of stuff and they,
they won their battles against the Jews in Galilee first and they run through
Galilee on the way to Jerusalem.
They get to Jerusalem around 68 and for two years they're besieging the city of
Jerusalem.
What if mark has written right at that time before Jerusalem had had been taken
before the temple had actually been destroyed because he has Jesus predict,
like Daniel prayed in some abomination of desolation happening in the temple,
but we don't know of anything like that.
Really that happened is a historical event,
right?
Then the temple was simply destroyed by the Romans.
They didn't as far as we might think,
well maybe he thinks that they're going to set up a Roman standard there or do
something,
but we're not narrated what actually happened,
what,
but so this and this scenario,
Mark writes his gospel with this message.
Things are going to get a lot worse before they get better and just like they
got a lot worse for Jesus before they got better,
they're going to get a lot worse for us before they get better.
And you need to be prepared because if you think that the Romans are gonna win
and we're all going to be carried off into slavery,
you don't have the right faith.
Jesus told us this,
Jesus told us it wouldn't be all pine,
the sky by and by.
It wouldn't be all good stuff.
We're going to have to suffer just like he suffered.
And he writes this Gospel message that over and over again has Jesus saying,
suffering must precede glory.
Suffering must precede glory.
Even as Jesus predict around the time when all this will happen.
When you see Jerusalem says,
you know,
with Jerusalem is surrounded by Roman armies who were pagans,
you can pretty well guess that something's gonna happen.
So I believe that the gospel of Mark May have been written right before 70 all
right around 70 but the destruction of the temple has not sunk into
consciousness yet or is not known to happen.
And maybe even mark himself and his disciples are themselves in Galilee.
Maybe this is why he says we're supposed to be in Galilee waiting for Jesus,
and then he will appear to us when all is worse,
when it just seems like everything's couldn't get worse.
I tr,
I tell you,
he's gonna come in on the clouds and he'll destroy the Romans and he'll set up
the Kingdom of God.
If he's doing this,
it makes a lot of sense for the document also ending where it ends,
it says,
tell them to go to Galilee and weight.
Okay.
And Jesus goes to Galilee to meet them in a sense marks telling his readers,
all we have to do is stay here and he'll come for us.
Okay.
That's one historical reading of the gospel of mark that plates,
it places it and one not provable time.
Some scholars believe mark was written in Rome.
Some people believe it was written after 70 I would say if mark was written
after 70 very long after 70 I would clearly expect him to narrate the
destruction of Jerusalem and the destruction of the temple as Luke does.
When you read Luke,
who used mark is one of his sources.
You'll notice that the writer of the gospel of Luke uses this passage out of
mark and he edits it to add in the destruction of the temple before Jesus comes
back.
The reason,
because the writer of Luke knew that the temple had been destroyed.
Why does it Mark Keller about it?
Because he doesn't know yet.
That has been destroyed.